[Music]
oh
bruh what that smells like [ __ ] ass
am i eating arse juice what is this
nigeria what are you doing
[Music]
i haven't tried a nigerian food in a
while so
i have no idea what's gonna happen here
alright
hey plantain chips of course and uh
walkers oh this could be close you know
let me try the walkers first
oh
[Music]
so good contain chips
okay well
don't get me wrong it's decent
not even very decent but
this just edges it around yeah
salt and vinegar walkers literally the
best crisps
england wins this round baby
oh okay scrumpy jack
i have no idea where is cider okay
takeem
palm drink i don't know
okay
we'll save this grumpy jack
it's like a recorder leg
right am you
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is that
oh bro what that smells like [ __ ] ass
am i eating ass juice what is this
obviously i'm a man that tastes ah
so i know what ass tastes like this is
when you
you go in too deep i've never tried this
in my life
and i hope to never try it again the
worst drink i've
ever tasted nigeria what are you doing
england wins fam all right
here we go
it's empty it's so african man
there we go i found one
oh oh mate i don't even need to try
these
oh my god ah it's been so long
there holy yo
yeah i'm taking these from yeah yeah
yeah yeah man tastes like heaven baby
true love there's always like cringe in
it
sardines obviously i've had these
let's
it's see a bit sad doesn't it yeah this
fish had a sad
life this fish went through 2020 and was
like just killed me already
dry catfish baby
oh oh
oh just takes me back
oh
now nigeria wins all right what do we
have here
oh okay what is this
so if i'm being honest i have no idea
it's just a spicy fishy
like mix of just stuff
oh it's nice now this is a scotch egg
oh oh
oh no no
man that ain't the one finesse that egg
poor chicken poor chicken man nigeria's
the winner
whoop okay ooh humdums all right i know
these
and uh chin chin
no i have no i've had these it's like a
sugary biscuit
but it's just just blind man they're
just a bit
dead am i being honest
[Music]
texture
[Music]
finesse i do love a hobnob
england wins with this one yeah
and that was snap walls for lab bible uh
wow what what a journey oh journey guys
uh so i've decided to take uh la bibles
tomtoms
and keep them for me tough
my presence
is mine
what's his name smegel